il
[Musique]
on
non
une petite route du dakota du sud bien
loin de washington de new york ou de los
angeles
nous sommes à supporter
ici on est au coeur des grandes plaines
et de l'amérique de george bush on croit
à la supériorité des états unis à la
grandeur de la bannière étoilée et
surtout à la bonté et au pouvoir du
christ
[Musique]
lesley ann haute et évangéliste
nous sommes au coeur de l'amérique
profonde
vous êtes né ici
oui à 6 falls dans le dakota du sud
j'adore ce message je suis une vraie
fille des plaines
leslie fait partie de ces nouveaux
chrétiens qui ont décidé de changer le
visage des états unis
les vraies valeurs de l'amérique c'est
ici qu'on la trouve et j'y suis très
attaché
aujourd'hui les skis a rendez vous dans
l'un des plus grands lycées de la région
pour donner un cours un peu particulier
bonjour ça va c'est vraiment cool ce que
vous faites
chaque semaine les skis et ses
collaboratrices sillonnent les écoles de
l'état pour diffuser un message qui
aurait fait sourire il ya encore dix ans
donnez nous quelques secondes pour que
l'on s'installe et on pourra commencer
ok pas de problème un message qui
aujourd'hui est pris très au sérieux par
les enseignants
s'il vous plaît je voudrais vous
présenter leslie en russe c'est la
présidente du centre national pour
l'abstinence jusqu'au mariage
veuillez lui souhaiter la bienvenue
aujourd'hui nous allons traiter d'un
sujet dont tout le monde parle mais sur
lequel personne ne vous dis la vérité
pour vous faire comprendre j'ai amené ce
très beau ça
mais vous allez voir qu'à l'intérieur
s'est rempli de choses pas très jolies
car on vous ment régulièrement on
découvre de nouvelles maladies
sexuellement transmissibles
combien pensez-vous qu'il y en ait
et bien plus d'une trentaine
alors revenons à ce joli sac si
boursiers les gants
aussi beau et glamour que l'image qu'on
vous donne du sexe
hollywood vous montre toutes ces stars
qui dans les films se rencontrent
s'embrasser tombe amoureux et à la fin
il y a toujours un magnifique coucher de
soleil à votre avis qu'est ce qui leur
arrive ensuite
moi je vais vous le dire peut-être
qu'ils ont attrapé chaque lame il ya par
exemple du nom d'une maladie
sexuellement transmissible
tiens toi mais le autour du cou
montra toute la classe comme t'es mignon
alors c'est les filles c'est
spécialement pour vous
vous sentez rien puis un beau jour vous
avez une inflammation et vous devenez
stériles et les mecs le transmettent
sans même savoir qu'ils l'ont hockey
lui c'est vincent verrue une virus
sexuellement transmissibles bien sûr il
faut se la faire enlever si on ne veut
pas qu'ils provoquent un cancer
et là tout le monde reconnaissait
rachida et ça c'est la mort assurée si
vous coucher par exemple avec un mec est
que lui a couché avec une autre fille
qui elle même a couché avec un autre mec
quand vous couchez avec le premier vous
couchez avec tous les autres
l'abstinence si vous y pensez souvent
je suis bien obligé mes parents
n'arrêtent pas de me dire que si je ne
reste pas vierge aurait de gros soucis
et puis la plus grosse épidémie de tout
c'est lui le bébé bernard
et non lui il s'attrape super facilement
élever un bébé bernard au lycée si
beaucoup de stress les mecs
on vous les filles vous en connaissez
beaucoup des garçons qui ont les moyens
d'élever un enfant
alors bien sûr on vous donne des pilules
des poudres et des pommades pour traiter
toutes ces maladies mais vous n'êtes
plus intelligent que ça n'est ce pas
votre organe sexuel le plus important il
est là haut de toute façon c'est dans le
mariage que le sexe est le meilleur
les serpents c'est très biblique vous
pensez que l'amérique a oublié ce qu'est
le péché
vous savez je n'ai pas le droit de
parler de religion dans une école
publique
d'accord mais vous avez quand même pris
les serpents pour exemple non disons que
c'est plutôt pour la peur qu'ils
inspirent aux gens c'est dégoûtant c'est
juste pour ça
les skis et évangéliste mais elle n'a
pas le droit de parler ouvertement de
religion dans les écoles publiques
son programme sur l'abstinence est
financé par de l'argent du contribuable
elle ne doit faire aucune référence
directe à la bible ou adieu sous peine
de se voir retirer son budget
et vous les gars sont abstinents
jusqu'au mariage c'est possible ouais
peut-être mais franchement on verra
comment les choses évoluent
[Applaudissements]
bon n'oubliez pas de prendre ces
prospectus il y a des stylos gratuit
aussi et ça ce sont des ballons pas des
capotes hockey
quelqu'un croyais que c'était des
préservatifs l'autre jour
[Musique]
sioux falls la seule grande ville d'un
état essentiellement rural ici
l'industrie lourde a fait faillite
depuis longtemps et après la crise des
années 80 c'est aujourd'hui vers dieu
que beaucoup de gens se tournent dans
l'espoir d'un avenir meilleur
les skis elle s'en sort plutôt bien sa
fondation pour l'abstinence jusqu'au
mariage est la plus importante des états
unis
sa notoriété a depuis longtemps dépassé
les murs des écoles et son nom résonne
jusque dans les couloirs du congrès à
washington
mère au foyer avant de prendre la tête
de la croisade pour l'abstinence elle
est devenue une figure politique engagé
sur tous les fronts de la droite
conservatrice américaine un engagement
qui lui vaut d'être appréciée par le
président bush lui même
qui veut réduire notre budget le
ministère de la santé des coureurs autre
d'argent
une fois de plus ce matin laisse qui
doit affronter ses adversaires des
organisations laïques qui tentent
régulièrement de faire réduire son
budget au profit de programmes en faveur
de la contraception
je veux qu'on appelle tous nos contacts
tous ceux qui nous soutiennent
leslie est devenu maître dans l'art du
lobbying toutes ces employés vont ce
matin battre le rappel des hommes
politiques qu'elle a soutenue au cours
des dernières élections qu'est ce qui se
passe là
certaines lois visant à interdire
l'enseignement de l'abstinence sont en
train d'être votée donc nous devons
rester vigilants state
ligne je veux m'assurer de ne pas perdre
les états dans lesquels je suis bien
implanté américaines chez nos ennemis
veulent récupérer ma part du budget pour
financer l'utilisation de la pilule ou
des préservatifs
c'est ici que l'on gère tous les
programmes d'abstinence dans le pays il
y en a plusieurs milliers
donc vous n'êtes pas inventé qu'au-delà
quotas du sud bien sûr que non nous
avons des associés dans tous les états
unis et
oui et ce programme ne cesse de grandir
vous savez quand j'ai commencé en 1995
nous n'étions que six femmes six mères
de famille
c'est moi qui a fait le choix de
m'occuper de la partie centrale du pays
après j'ai décidé de créer un bureau
capable de gérer tous nos besoins
à l'époque on avait que des polycopiés
cd terre
moi je voulais des plaquettes en couleur
pour plaire aux jeunes
depuis leslie trouve chaque mois de
nouvelles idées
dvd porte clés bijoux tee shirt tout est
bon pour vendre l'abstinence comme une
idée moderne
tout est bon pour séduire les jeunes
tenez regardez ça ça c'est une carte de
garantie de virginité
le principe est simple les parents
l'offre à leurs enfants et l'enfant
signe au bas de la carte c'est une façon
de rappeler aux jeunes qu'il a fait une
promesse celle de rester vierge
vous voyez c'est tout petit on peut
l'emporter par toulouse donc son porte
monnaie ou dans son sac à main mais
non je ne dis pas le sexe est horrible
au contraire je dis le sexe génial alors
il faut attendre jusqu'au mariage
et pour leslie on est jamais trop jeune
pour s'engager sur la voie de
l'abstinence après les ados sont notre
cible préférée ce sont les enfants des
maternelles
cet après midi elle a organisé un thé
spécial intitulé dieu ma mère et moi
[Musique]
tout ici est fait pour séduire les
petites filles ballons roses tartelette
aux fraises et musique douce une
véritable ambiance de conte de fées
leslie est ici chez elle alors cette
fois elle peut ouvertement exprimé ses
convictions chrétiennes
aujourd'hui je veux célébrer la pureté
et l'innocence de ses petites filles
regardez dans leurs yeux c'est ça la
vraie pureté moi je veux simplement
préserver toute cette innocence
au programme de cet après midi un conte
très spécial écouter les enfants il va
maintenant vous lire une très belle
histoire et sedin a qui va vous l'allier
le comte s'appelle la princesse et le
baiser caisse
[Applaudissements]
était une fois une princesse en âge de
se marier
son père le roi invite à la cour tous
ses prétendants oui lui dit
fais attention ma fille et réfléchit
bien
d'accord ton premier baiser cas celui
qui deviendra pour marier car ce premier
baiser est un cadeau de dieu alors
surtout ne le gâchez
préserver leur premier baiser pour
l'homme qu'elle épouseront un slogan que
ces petites filles vont entendre pendant
bien des années encore
je trouve ça formidable ce genre
d'événement
ça me permet de créer une véritable
relation de confiance avec mes filles
quand elles seront plus âgés elles
n'auront pas au monde de me parler de
leurs problèmes et nous pourrons les
résoudre ensemble
c'est triste que dans notre pays britney
spears soit montrée en exemple mais il
faut faire avec
c'est un mois d'enseigner les vraies
valeurs à mes filles
m'ont mouvement pour la pureté
l'abstinence a pour but de créer de
jolis souvenirs chez ces enfants dès
leur plus jeune âge
aujourd'hui les filles vont recevoir une
photo d'elle et ramené plein de petits
cadeaux
en fait ce qu'on est en train de faire
c'est fabriquer des sourires de pureté
pour toutes ces petites filles
exceptionnellement la semaine prochaine
les ce qui n'ira pas à prêcher la petite
anse dans les lycées elle a rendez-vous
à washington pour défendre son budget
[Musique]
nous sommes à 500 km au nord de sioux
falls dans l'état voisin du dakota du
sud le minnesota
encore un état dans lequel les
évangélistes sont en train de
s'implanter
[Musique]
chaque cri pcaa lui aussi est
évangéliste comme de plus en plus
d'américains il laisse au christ le soin
de diriger sa ni
ce qu'est marié il a cinq enfants trois
petits enfants et une particularité il y
à 25 ans dieu s'est adressé à lui pour
lui demander de devenir un meilleur
chrétiens
depuis la voix divine lui parle
régulièrement
rien qui n'étonne cathy sa femme
évangélistes elle aussi katy c'est une
belle vue que vous avez ici
et en été le soleil se couche
directement en face de la maison c'est
superbe d'ailleurs c'est sur le ponton
que nos enfants se sont mariés il y a
deux ans
damas est la belle-fille de chuck elle a
épousé taner son fils avant son mariage
les récits de son beau-père l'inquiétait
un peu
raconté mois quand vous avez rencontré
le choc pour la première fois vous en
avez pensé quoi
ce qu'il est quand même bizarre
bien sûr tout le monde m'a accueilli à
bras ouverts dans la famille la famille
n'était pas aussi croyant et je n'avais
pas cette fois qu'ils ont tous j'ai du
temps à me faire
depuis je me suis converti ses
différents jésus est entré dans ma vie
aujourd'hui je prie tout le temps
vous savez que dans certains pays si
vous dites que dieu vous parle vous
risquez de vous retrouver en hôpital
psychiatrique
c'est vrai mais quand du a commencé à me
parler à me demander de faire certaines
choses je me suis vraiment inquiété
alors je me suis dit qu'on allait me
prendre pour un fou je croyais que
j'étais fou
c'est sûr que d'un point de vue laïque
entendre une voix divine c'est
inconcevable 1
mais j'ai une confiance aveugle en dieu
et lorsqu'il me demande de faire quelque
chose j'obéis ces instructions sont très
précises dieu m'a toujours dit chuck
mais je ne te ferai jamais perdre de
temps
[Musique]
chaque vie à l river c'est ici qu'il a
grandi
a priori rien ne différencie cette
petite ville de milliers d'autres
petites villes des états unis
pourtant la majorité des vingt mille
habitants d'el rivers a décidé comme
chuck de vivre au rythme de dieu
alors ici on trouve des églises bien sûr
beaucoup d'églises mais aussi des
restaurants chrétiens des magasins
chrétiens et la toute première banque
chrétienne et c'est chuck qui la dirige
maintenant depuis deux ans
nous sommes au coeur des rêveurs c'est
ici que dieu travail mais pourquoi dieu
a choisi le creeper et pourquoi pas new
york ou washington
dieu va s'installer partout
mais je lui ai souvent demandé pourquoi
il avait d'abord choisi l'écrivain et
pas une autre ville
non et dieu m'a répondu qu'il fallait
bien commencer quelque part par une
ville vous savez ici nous ne sommes que
vingt mille habitants
alors forcément lorsque dieu répond à
nos prières tout le monde peut s'en
rendre compte
alors tchèque a décidé de faire de sa
banque une annexe de l'église
la riverview community bank est la
première banque chrétienne du minnesota
de l'extérieur rien d'inhabituel à part
peut-être la très pieuse de vis du
dollar nous croyons en dieu inscrits
devant l'entrée
à l'intérieur chaque a fait
symboliquement enterré une bible dans
les fondations
démarré avec un capital de seulement 5
millions de dollars la banque de chuck
après deux ans à peine d'existence fait
aujourd'hui plus de 90 millions de
chiffre d'affaires
une véritable réussite c'est même la
banque qui a le plus fort taux de
croissance de tout l'état du minnesota
ce matin chaque cas rendez vous avec
richard maddox un nouveau client qui
cherche à obtenir un prêt
vous m'aviez dit au téléphone que vous
cherchez à obtenir un prêt pour votre
entreprise de travaux publics
oui
et si j'ai bien compris vous avez eu des
soucis financiers avant
bien vous aurez besoin de combien
à peu près 20 mille dollars
je pense qu'il faut d'abord prié pour
votre prennent
pour être sûr que vous êtes dans la
bonne voie mais surtout que dieu nous
accorde sa bénédiction
ça vous dérangerait pas de juste me
faire une prière personnelle
j'arrive pas à arrêter de fumer j'ai
tout essayé
alors prions pour votre problème de
cigarettes et ensuite on paiera pour le
prêt et ainsi vous allez voir du à
l'heure vous savez dans notre banque il
ya tout un réseau d'entreprises
chrétiennes qui sont prêtes à vous aider
en temps normal ce serait chacun pour
soi mais ces gens là sont de bons
chrétiens dieu les a aidé dans le passé
et aujourd'hui ils veulent renvoyer
l'ascenseur et maintenant prions
seigneur tout puissant je voudrais
accueilli richard dans cette banque et
je vous demande de le bénir et de le
guider je vous demande aussi mon dieu de
bénir cette transaction financière que
nous apprêtons à signer
[Musique]
mon seigneur tout puissant fait qu'à
chaque fois que richard a envie de tirer
sur une cigarette qu'il puisse plus tôt
dans votre force et que vous les 10 à
combattre sa dépendance
seigneur merci d'avoir guidé richard
jusqu'à notre bande fait que nous
puissions l'aider au nom du christ amen
vias
waouh c'est incroyable je vous aime
qu'est ce qui s'est passé
j'ai des fourmis dans les mains
il est étrange de prix etc sans
banquiers non bien sûr mais certaines
personnes font des heures de route pour
pris avec moi elles ne sont même pas pu
vous imaginez la détresse de ces gens
qui ont besoin de briller dans une
banque moi ce que je veux c'est
transformé leur vie avec l'aide du
christ
et puis s'ils deviennent clients par la
suite tant mieux
c'est de bon qui est vraiment différente
vous savez
quand on est noir en amérique tout le
monde vous regarde de travers
comme quand je rentre dans un magasin
par exemple
mais dans cette banque les employés ont
bien reçu et m'ont dit bonjour que je
vous aider
c'était très chaleureux j'avais
l'impression d'être à l'église ah bon tu
es noir je m'en suis même pas rendu
compte
ok jack n'est que le vice-président de
la banque son patron c'est dwayne
propulse qu' un homme de peu de mots
mais à la foi inébranlable
ils se sont réparti les rôles chuck
s'occupe des relations publiques et
dwayne lui gère les affaires
quotidiennes de la banque
puis beaucoup ça veut dire quoi être une
bande chrétienne
d'abord en tant que banquier je dois
respecter les lois et m'assurer que les
non chrétiens se sentent bienvenus s'ils
veulent obtenir un prêt par exemple
d'ailleurs moi je préfère avoir des
clients qui ne sont pas encore chrétiens
ça me donne l'occasion de leur parler et
du christ et peut-être de les convertir
si tous nos clients étaient chrétiens
alors je ne serais pas en train de
travailler pour dieu
mais pourquoi le besoin d'une banque
chrétien
je me suis rendu compte en regardant
notre pays que nous sommes devenus une
société immoral et sans éthique
prenez l'exemple des grands scandales
financiers comme enron ou les dirigeants
trafic et la comptabilité pour
s'enrichir il n'avait aucune éthique
c'est pour ça que l'amérique doit
revenir à des valeurs chrétiennes et à
une conduite plus morale et si possible
le monde entier avec elle
j'ai accroché ce tableau dans mon bureau
parce que je cherchais un symbole qui
exprimerait clairement à mes clients et
à mes amis mes convictions chrétiennes
ce que j'ai voulu dire par là c'est que
jésus-christ est au coeur du monde du
travail il ne faut pas seulement le
suivre dans sa vie privée mais aussi
dans sa vie professionnelle
mais le christ a chassé les marchands du
temple et c'était les banquiers de
l'époque non
il faut regarder la bible dans son
contexte
bien sûr que jésus a chassé les
marchands qui utilisait le temps de
façon impropre mais si nous prêtons de
l'argent avec une morale avec une
éthique dieu ne va pas nous chasser nous
sommes ici dans sa bande et respect
en plus de sa banque tchèque s'occupe
d'un groupe de prière chaque mercredi
tous les notables dale crover se
retrouve dans la seule bibliothèque de
la ville un rendez vous qu'il ne
manquerait pour rien au monde depuis six
ans ils sont une petite vingtaine de
fidèles il y à madame le maire les
pasteurs évangélistes des différentes
congrégations bien sûr et aussi le
recteur des écoles publiques le principe
est simple priez pour résoudre les
problèmes de la ville
m'a dit quelques river serait le
détonateur de la révolution chrétienne
dans tous les états unis car comme il
l'a fait dans ma banque dieu veut
montrer au reste du monde toute sa force
et sa puissance et notre petite ville
est un exemple du changement qu'il est
capable d'apporter
pendant plus d'une heure ce conseil
municipal un peu particulier va demander
l'aide de dieu pour combattre ce que
tout le monde appelle ici les forces du
mal c'est le recteur des écoles qui
ouvre la séance
je pense que notre ville est un
sanctuaire pour beaucoup de gens et nous
avons de très grande responsabilité
envers nos citoyens
nous sommes en train de transformer
notre vie mais je veux vous mettre en
garde
satan lui-même est en train de nous
attaquer c'est dans ces moments que les
hommes de dieu doivent se battre
je dis tout ça parce que des promoteurs
veulent construire un casino chez nous
bien sûr beaucoup de gens pensent que ce
casino sera une source d'emplois pour
notre communauté mais en réalité ce
n'est qu'une source de malfaisance et
nous avons besoin d' aide pour empêcher
ça
bon alors ceux qui veulent prier pour le
recteur
regroupez-vous autour de lui
seigneur nous avons entendu la requête
de notre recteur nous avons vu les
conséquences de ces casinos dans
d'autres communautés et nous vous
supplions d'agir d'agir d'agir contre ce
projet de casino
mon dieu trancher avec votre relève la
main de sa tante qui tente d'implanter
un casino dans notre ville mais aussi
dans toute la région
que votre lumière éclaire notre
gouverneur pour l'aider à trouver un
autre moyen d'équilibrer le budget de
l'état nous n'avons pas besoin de
l'argent des casinos
au nom de jésus-christ tout puissant
nous attendons un signe de votre
puissance
et merci de nous avoir donné un tel
recteur et béni soit sa femme et sa
famille protéger le au nom du christ
notre ville est vraiment unique
car nous sommes tous unis dans le corps
du christ ici rien ne nous divise
et si on n'est pas chrétien on peut
vivre ici elle crie veut bien sûr vous
savez dans ce pays si on n'aime pas la
politique d'un maire il suffit d'en
élire un autre aux prochaines élections
mais depuis que je suis élu mon
programme est simple
le vrai changement ne s'obtient que par
la prière
le shérif passe en coup de vent lui
aussi à une requête urgente
sur quoi veux tu compris aujourd'hui
vous savez tous qu'avec l'arrivée du
printemps c'est aussi le moment de
l'année où il ya une recrudescence des
crimes et des délits
et c'est valable pour tout le comté de
chaouen way dans tout le comté
prions tous pour scott
seigneur dieu tout d'abord nous vous
remercions de nous avoir donné scott
comme chérie mais
c'est un homme bon et pieux
alors mon dieu fait régner la paix dans
tout le comté
protéger tous nos concitoyens
[Musique]
revenir au principe même de la bible
pour mieux faire régner l'ordre et la
justice l'idée a germé ici à montgomery
dans l'alabama
[Musique]
c'est un baiser talent les plus
religieux du sud de l'amérique
[Musique]
cette voiture c'est celle du juge roy
humour l'homme par qui le scandale est
arrivé il y a deux ans alors qu'il était
président de la cour suprême d'alabama
il a fait installer une reproduction en
marbre du texte des dix commandements
dans le hall du palais de justice
depuis le juge rahim moore a été
contraint de démissionner mais sa
reproduction en marbre des dix
commandements est devenu un objet culte
qui fait le tour de l'amérique chrétiens
c'est la première fois depuis six mois
que la sculpture vient en alabama
tenez je vous présente le directeur de
la coalition chrétienne de l'alabama
ça fait combien de temps que vous n'avez
pas vu les dix commandements
ça fait longtemps je n'ai vu que deux
fois depuis qu'il a été retiré du palais
de justice
et nous c'est la première fois depuis
quatre ans depuis qu'on l'a construit
l'objet du scandale le voici un bloc de
marbre de plus de 3 tonnes sur lequel
est gravé chacun des dix commandements
quand ils ne voyagent pas il est
entreposé dans cette marbrerie
chrétienne bien sûr
dites donc vous l'avez vraiment bien
nettoyer
mais on va faire un deuxième lavage il y
avait beaucoup de traces de mains sur
toute cette partie
il est plus propre que la dernière fois
que j'ai vu et puis c'était vraiment
très seul
c'est normal lorsque le monument était
acclamée dans tout le pays des milliers
de gens l'ont touchée il y avait des
traces de mains partout c'est surtout ça
qu'on a nettoyé
depuis que le juge moore a démissionné
des milliers de militants évangélistes
lui expriment leur soutien à travers le
pays des shérifs des juges dénonce le
déclin moral de la société américaine et
réclame symboliquement le retour des dix
commandements dans tous les lieux
publics
depuis 60 ans maintenant la justice
américaine s'est éloigné de la parole de
dieu
et ce monument a pour but de rappeler à
tous les principes de base de notre
société
c'est pour ça que vous avez fait
construire le monument
oui aussi pour apprendre aux américains
que c'est comme au mans sont à l'origine
de toute moralité
c'est la morale d'un individu qui permet
de se contrôler
un homme de bonne moralité n'a pas
besoin d'être constamment rappelée à
l'ordre il sait se contrôler et ça c'est
la définition même de la moralité et
pendant quelqu'un de morale ne tue pas
ne vole pas ne ment pas et ne commet pas
d'adultère avocat parce qu'on va à la
pêche mais bien parce que si moralement
répréhensible et lorsque le monument a
été retirée qu'est ce que vous avez
ressenti
j'étais triste quand on cache la parole
de dieu on cache aussi les principes
fondateurs de notre pays
c'est en haut de ces marches en plein
centre de montgomery que le juge avait
installé son monument juste à l'entrée
du palais de justice bien en vue entre
ces deux drapeaux
une provocation que comme beaucoup
d'américains robert varlet et william
mes serres n'ont pas supporté
avocats ce sont eux qui ont demandé et
obtenu la démission du juge moore au nom
de la séparation entre l'église et
l'état
on peut se demander quelles étaient les
intentions du juge en faisant venir ici
ce monument eh bien il a été très clair
pendant son procès pour lui ce monument
c'est le symbole des dix commandements
c'est la toute puissance de dieu la
toute puissance d'un vieux protestant
bien sûr placé au dessus des lois de
notre pays c'est pour ça que la cour
nous a donné raison et a ordonné le
retrait du monument
certains évangélistes ont pris le
contrôle de nos institutions pour
essayer d'imposer leur croyance au reste
du pays
ils ne sont en aucun cas la majorité des
évangélistes mais il semblerait que
dernièrement il est acquis un véritable
pouvoir
on sait ce que ça donne lorsque des
fondamentalistes religieux prennent le
pouvoir
on a vu ce qu'on fait des talibans en
afghanistan
c'est ça notre grande peur
mais le juge moore et ses partisans
n'ont pas dit leur dernier mot c'est
dans cette maison coloniale en plein
coeur du quartier chic de montgomery que
le juge a installé sa fondation pour le
droit moral entouré de jeunes avocats
c'est d'ici qu'il organise la défense de
tous ceux qui pour avoir suivi son
exemple sont aujourd'hui à leur tour
attaqué en justice
[Musique]
je crois que nous allons gagner notre
procès en géorgie mais d'une façon
générale les cours d'état attendent une
décision de la cour suprême avant de se
prononcer
sauf au michigan le gouverneur nous a
dit qu'elle soutenait notre combat pour
les dix commandements
oui c'est vrai mais malheureusement sous
la pression elle s'est rétractée depuis
même chose en géorgie le gouverneur
avait pourtant promis de mettre un
monument à l'entrée du conseil général
mais finalement il s'est contenté de le
mettre dans son bureau
vous savez je pense que les politiciens
ne se rendent pas compte de l'ampleur du
phénomène
d'ici à ce que la cour suprême rende son
verdict ils vont subir une telle
pression qu'ils seront contraints d'agir
parce que de plus en plus d'américains
comprennent l'importance de notre corps
pourquoi êtes vous venu travailler pour
le juge
pour la même raison que j'ai fait mes
études de droit dans une université
chrétienne
c'est important de comprendre l'origine
divine de nos lois
en première année j'ai étudié le droit
bien sûr mais aussi la bible
ce qui m'a plu chez le juge moore c'est
son courage il n'a pas honte de ses
convictions chrétiennes
d'ailleurs je les rejoins le jour où il
a installé les dix commandements dans le
palais de justice
avant de rejoindre le juge moore dans
l'état d'alabama ce jeune avocat a fait
ses études de droit en virginie sur la
côte est des états unis
[Musique]
plus précisément à regent universités
c'est la plus grande faculté de droit
chrétienne du pays le fer de lance de
l'idéologie évangélistes
[Musique]
ici depuis 25 ans des étudiants tous
d'horizons très différents se retrouvent
pour faire honneur à la devise de leur
école une élite chrétienne pour changer
le monde
dans cette salle de plats spécialement
transformé en tribunal les étudiants en
troisième année de droit s'apprête à
simuler un procès méar agent aucun cours
ne commence sans une prière aujourd'hui
elle est en musique
[Musique]
l'homme qui officie à la guitare est
l'un des professeurs de droit les plus
respectés du campus james dwayne est
sorti premier de sa promotion harvard il
a longtemps été l'un des plus
redoutables juristes du pays aujourd'hui
ils oeuvrent pour dieu
[Musique]
bien sous-louer
on peut l'applaudir
- comme pourquoi êtes vous venue
enseigner ici je suis sûr que vos
services seraient très appréciées
harvard ou dans d'autres facultés aussi
connu
j'adore enseigner dans cette école
discours des élèves ici ont une
véritable intégrité la fondation mort
olsen qui le regardent leur part je ne
peux pas en dire autant de mes camarades
de classe de harvard il était sympa
mais surtout insolent prétentieux simple
de leur personne il n'avait aucune
habilité et ne cherchait que la gloire
c'est une assez bonne description de
secours mais ici à ma grande surprise
les étudiants de ce campus cherche
d'abord à suivre la parole de dieu à
travers mon enseignement
et art agent on a déjà une petite idée
de ce à quoi devrait ressembler la
justice américaine
je voudrais ouvrir cette séance comme on
a l'habitude de le faire dans toutes les
salles d'audience du pays
au nom du père du fils et du
saint-esprit
seigneur jésus donnez-nous votre
bénédiction lors de ce procès ait fait
que notre jugement soit impartial et
juste
il donc ça se passe pas tout à fait
comme ça
non pas encore
pendant près de quatre heures les élèves
du professeur douanes vont encore une
fois rôder leurs techniques de défense
et leurs arguments dans quelques mois
ils vont devoir défendre leur vision
chrétienne de la justice dans de vrais
tribunaux et face à d'autres brillants
arica formés dans les meilleures
universités like
you go valverde justement vient de
déserter une grande université d'état
pour rejoindre ridge
en arrivant ici ma première inquiétude a
été que les profs ne soit pas à la
hauteur des autres farces et rapidement
je me suis rendu compte qu'il était et
en plus ils ont la conviction religieuse
ils comprennent l'importance de leur
rôle et de la mission de notre école est
en fin de compte et profits s'ils sont
bien meilleurs que ceux de mon ancienne
université
de pause
qu'est ce que vos étudiants apporteront
en plus dans les salles d'audience du
pays enfin j'espère que leur foi
chrétienne en feront des avocats intègre
honnête et droit ces valeurs sont aussi
enseigné dans les écoles laïques mais il
ya tellement d'avocats malhonnête
aujourd'hui que c'est à se demander de
quelle façon on leur apprend l'intégrité
les grands principes de notre justice
sont toutes d'origine divine et je pense
que mes élèves comprennent bien ça
hugo est d'origine latino-américaine une
communauté traditionnellement catholique
mais qui depuis quelques années se
convertit de plus en plus à
l'évangélisme
c'est difficile d' appartenir à une
minorité ethnique dans cette école
absolument pas
je n'ai jamais ressenti la moindre
discrimination dans cette école
personne ne m'a jamais fait de remarques
ou de commentaires désobligeants
[Applaudissements]
pourtant les évangélistes sont
majoritairement blancs
n'ont pas ici en tout cas vous savez les
minorités ethniques sont de plus en plus
nombreuses dans cette école il y a des
évangélistes asiatique des évangélistes
sud-américain et regardez même moi je
suis un guen évangélistes c'est un
mouvement en pleine croissance
et ils sont de plus en plus nombreux aux
états unis à choisir un cursus
universitaire chrétiens aujourd'hui à
regent's ces journées portes ouvertes
plus de 800 candidats sont venues de
toute l'amérique pour rencontrer
professeurs et étudiants
il y a dix ans des journées comme
celle-ci n'a tiré qu'une petite centaine
de candidats pour répondre aux questions
des futurs étudiants et d accueillir
hugo a été réquisitionnée pourquoi
voulez-vous venir à reggio
j'ai toujours voulu être avocate mais il
y a une telle corruption dans ce métier
tant de scandales impliquant les avocats
que je ne savais pas où aller
je me suis dit car agent je pourrais y
apporter ma foi et mes convictions pour
essayer de changer tout ça
en
france vous êtes encore sous l'influencé
de sa de nietzsche ces grands penseurs
qui aujourd'hui ont fait faillite
intellectuellement parce que leur
philosophie n'étaient pas fondées sur
les enseignements du christ
moi j'ai fait sciences po à paris et mes
profs m'ont dit qu'il n'y avait pas de
vérité suprême que tout pouvait être
argumenté bien moi je trouve ça
dangereux lanester
dans dix jours à washington la cour
suprême des etats unis va débattre de la
sphère des dix commandements et beaucoup
de jeunes juristes de bridgend feront le
déplacement pour défendre le juge moore
combattre les crimes avec l'aide du
christ une idée qui fait son chemin en
amérique nous sommes à la frontière
entre le nevada et l'utah
[Musique]
nous sommes à plus de 150 km de la ville
la plus proche c'est ici dans ces
montagnes au milieu de nulle part que
depuis quelques années c'est tout vert
l'un des premiers camps de rééducation
par la parole du christ
la plupart de ces enfants ont été
envoyés par des juges écouter la parole
de dieu
[Musique]
ils ont entre 14 et 17 ans le camp est
tenu par des évangélistes comme mathieu
et les séjours varie entre 6 et 9 mois
pour les gars vous allez chercher du
bois pour faire un peu
pendant toutes les années 80 en matière
de rééducation la mode était aux
méthodes de l'armée
aujourd'hui les juges préfèrent la
prière aux chants militaires
dans sa mère m'a appelé ce matin
c'est sage aideront un coup de fil ok ça
marche mon père m'a dit qu'il
m'appellerait quoi on se sent un peu
perdu ici non et oui on est vraiment
isolé c'est juste dur d'être loin de ma
famille
mais c'est mes potes qui me manque le
plus
reda legado à 16 ans il est arrivé au
camp il y à cette loi lui ce sont ses
parents qui lui ont envoyé par mesure
préventive
en avant j'étais complètement différent
j'ai pris toutes sortes de drogues
sauf de l'acide
et puis j'arrêtais pas de fuguer
un soir deux mecs balèze sont entrés
dans ma chambre à trois heures du matin
ils m'ont dit qu'ils m'ont emmené dans
une école spéciale en
quelque sorte
oui on peut dire ça j'ai été escorté ici
mes parents ont payé un service d'escort
chrétiens pour m'emmener ici à l'époque
j'étais furieux
est depuis j'ai décidé d'accepter dieu
dans ma vie j'ai l'impression que ça
marche en tout cas je me sens mieux
depuis deux ans que mathieu l'éducateur
s'occupe des jeunes il n'y a eu aucune
tentative d'évasion
gratuit
la gloire de dieu et la beauté de ce
paysage qui nous entourent permet de
tempérer lumière de ces jeunes nous
sommes au milieu de nulle part alors pas
besoin de barrow ici ces garçons sont
libres et captifs en même temps de cette
façon ils peuvent tourner toute leur
attention
et monaco est
allé tout le monde on se met en place
quel que soit votre péché aussi grave
soit il dit le christ vous pardonnera
mais pour ça il faut l'accepter
il vous demande simplement de vous
soumettre à lui
et lorsque vous le ferez aux sirènes il
vous garantit le pardon il garanti et il
faut y
dieu est prêt à vous accepter
aujourd'hui prêt à sauver votre âme il
joue alex car demain il sera peut-être
trop tard mr
[Musique]
de retour dans la vallée ont fait
l'appel le moindre manquement à la
discipline du groupe est sanctionné
[Musique]
fais moi d'y penser
en avant
marche
ces systèmes non
nécessaire ce sont les garçons qui
s'impose ces règles mon rôle c'est de
les guider spirituellement d'en faire
des gens bien au quotidien il se gère
tout seul sauf cas
darline et marek sont mariés ils sont
évangéliste bien sûr et dirige le centre
vous savez je crois que dieu est en
train de transformer les appelait j'aime
vraiment ça
comme chaque après midi c'est l'heure de
la confession publique tour à tour
chacun doit avouer ses péchés de la
journée
10 et moi je me suis laissé aller à la
colère
que moi j ai manqué de respect envers
quelqu'un
et moi j'ai abusé de mon autorité de
son sens qu'au seul le christ a été dit
ces jeunes oui nous utilisons les
enseignements de la bible pour les
guider et nous essayons d'être un
exemple pour
chaque le programme les programmes
laïque fonctionne aussi bien sûr ils ne
font que changer le comportement
extérieur des jeunes
nous nous voulons transformer ces
garçons leur donner une nouvelle vision
du monde tu les changes et de
l'intérieur grâce à dieu
[Musique]
à quelques kilomètres de là le bâtiment
réservé exclusivement aux filles
certaines d'entre elles ont commis des
délits d'autres souffrent simplement de
dépression ou de troubles du
comportement
peu importe le problème ici tout se
soigne par la prière
[Musique]
darline chaperonne ce rituel quotidien
des prières collectives qui prennent des
allures de thérapie de groupe
lorsque les filles chantent des louanges
ensemble dieu se met au travail
quant à chelsea il soigne les coeurs de
ces jeunes filles réparé leur âme
[Musique]
à chaque fois je suis au bord des larmes
elles ont tant besoin dead et je sais
que dieu va s'en occuper
[Musique]
non
il faut attendre le soir et l'intimité
des dortoirs pour entendre un discours
un peu différent
on n'est pas tout des chrétiennes et 100
sauvetages ont la foi mais d'autres noms
mois avant j'étais plutôt branché
satanisme je ne suis pas une chrétienne
je n'ai pas la foi c'est fatiguant de
les entendre tous parler de dieu à
longueur de journée moi j'ai grandi dans
une famille très chrétienne c'est pour
ça que j'en suis dégoûté
christie ya 15 ans elle a commencé sa
conversion il y a tout juste une semaine
[Musique]
moi je crois en dieu il y a plein de
choses dans la bible qui ne sont pas
logiques la zone en mai il ya trop de
contradictions et mon cerveau ne peut
pas accepter toutes ces histoires comme
une véritable sens
dans une amérique qui a longtemps prôné
la liberté comme seul et unique principe
de vie ils sont pourtant de plus en plus
nombreux à chercher refuge dans la bible
nous sommes à une dizaine d'heures de
route de l'utah dans l'état voisin du
colorado
[Musique]
mark patrick est un ancien taulard et
héroïnomane sa vie il n'en donnait pas
cher il ya encore quelques années mais
depuis qu'il est venu s'installer à
colorado springs tout a changé
ici on est en terre divine gars
j'étais toxico avant je me battais tout
le temps j'adorais ça
j'ai passé beaucoup de temps en prison
et j'ai fait du mal à beaucoup de monde
les drogues étaient en train de me tuer
et puis le christ m'a sauvé alors dieu
m'a vidé comme un poisson et a fait de
moi un nouvel homme
et il m'a donné un choeur 9 et une
nouvelle âme c'était une renaissance
vous savez il m'a vraiment rafistolé
depuis sa conversion il y a quinze ans
marc est devenu père de famille
est aujourd'hui comme tous les dimanches
il avale en vitesse un petit déjeuner
pour ne pas être en retard à l'église
la drogue la violence l'alcool sévices
qu'ils longtemps créé souffrir par le
passé il ne les cache pas à ses enfants
ni à sa femme sharon
vous imaginer qu'un jour vous auriez des
enfants comme ça non
et quand ils sont nés je pensais qu'ils
auraient des doigts palmés ou quelque
chose
à cause de mon passé
vous savez moi non plus je n'étais pas
un ange un jour j'étais dans une grande
soirée on prenait tous de la drogue
dansaient autour d'un feu de joie
je suis allé faire pipi dans les bois et
je vous jure qu'en refermant ma
braguette j'ai eu une vision un
parchemin flottait devant moi et dessus
il y avait inscrit tous mes péchés je
suis tombé à genoux et j'ai demandé
pardon christ depuis ce jour c'était il
ya vingt ans je ne suis jamais revenu en
arrière
c'est un peu difficile pour vous
d'entendre vos parents parler comme ça
de leur passé de tout ce qu'ils ont fait
c'est vrai que c'est pas évident
l'imaginer en train de prendre de la
drogue et c'est aussi pour ça qu'ils
sont bons conseils pour moi et mon frère
ils sont l'exemple à ne pas suivre
et puis dieu les a tellement changé que
l'on se rend compte que le christ est
notre seul salut
marc a non seulement changé de vie mais
aussi de métier
cet ancien ouvrier du bâtiment est
devenu sculpteur mais bien sûr il a mis
son talent au service de dieu c'est ici
que je travaille le toit est
suffisamment haut pour sculpter de grand
oeuvre
et sa spécialité bien sûr ce sont les
anges
il y a des années lorsque je commençais
à lire la bible j'ai remarqué qu'aucun
des enjeux n'étaient défendre les anges
étaient tous des hommes de vrais durs à
cuire
capable de botter les fesses de
n'importe quel adversaire
des anges en bronze qu'il vend dans tous
les pays et à toutes les églises
voulait pendre et combien cela va de 130
dollars et les plus chers
soixante mille dollars et tous les
grands pasteurs évangélistes américains
en ont un c'est vraiment cool haute cour
comme marc et sa famille des milliers de
chrétiens sont venus s'installer à
colorado springs une ville nichée au
pied des rocheuses que certains
appellent même le vatican des
évangélistes je pense que tout le monde
à colorado springs même les non croyants
savent où se trouve notre église
l'église de marque et de sharon la voici
tous les dimanches c'est plus de onze
mille fidèles qui viennent prier ici
pour une messe pas comme les autres
et le pasteur de cette méga congrégation
lui non plus ne fait rien comme les eaux
ted haggard roule en scooter pour
inciter ses paroissiens à faire des
économies d'essence une hérésie au pays
des super 4 4
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui le pasteur a rendez vous
avec 800 nouveaux membres de son église
bonjour tout le monde comment allez-vous
regarder cette assemblée il fait la
taille de la plupart des paroisses mais
chez nous ce sont simplement de nouveaux
membres qui nous rejoignent ce mois-ci
annula et nous pensons atteindre
facilement les vingt mille membres
ted haggard a ouvert sa première église
dans les années 80 avec une vingtaine de
fidèles
aujourd'hui il est devenu l'un des
évangélistes les plus puissants du pays
sa formule est simple rester dans l'air
du temps et utiliser les dernières
technologies pour diffuser la parole du
christ
sommes dans le centre de prières
mondiale nous avons des équipes qui pris
ici 24 heures sur 24 et 7 jours sur 7
pour tous les pays du monde liste et
puis regardez nous avons même un site
internet ici sur les écrans plasma il
n'ya jamais moins de 70 milles personnes
qui prient en ligne si vous voulez que
l'on prie pour vous il suffit de nous
envoyer un courrier électronique
parfois nous organisons une première
mondiale imaginez 40 millions personnes
qui prient en ligne dans plus de 130
pays c'est incroyable écran plasma
prière via internet les nouveaux membres
ont même droit à une présentation vidéo
de l'église
bonjour à tous je m'appelle ted haggard
je suis le pasteur principal de nu life
et je suis ravi que vous soyez là avec
nous aujourd'hui j'espère que vous avez
aimé le petit déjeuner est franchement
j'espère que vous viendrez tous nous
rejoindre dans notre église vous savez à
new life tout le monde est merveilleux
c'est une véritable communauté et nous
avons besoin de vous
pendant dix minutes à vidéoclip va faire
la promotion des services offerts par
l'église de ted haggard
garderie vacances organisées petits
groupes dans près d' ici tout le monde a
une place quel que soit son passé
[Musique]
et comme le christ le pasteur ted
pardonne tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pendant ce temps dans le bâtiment
principal
7500 personnes se pressent pour le
service de 11
dans la foule pas de discrimination de
race de classe ni d'âge
et trônant au centre du hall d'entrée un
ange de 5 tonnes sculpté par notre
motard marque patrick est offert au
pasteur tél
[Musique]
à l'intérieur de l'église chacun prend
place pour écouter le sermon de ted haga
une fois n'est pas coutume car le
pasteur est souvent en déplacement dans
le pays
en tant que président de l'association
américaine des évangélistes il est
responsable de près de 45 à l'église aux
états unis en tout le pasteur ted parle
au nom de plus de 30 millions
d'américains
est bouclé a pris 1 ce matin
après le sermon du pasteur place à la
musique
[Musique]
c'est sympa
notre façon prier très moderne les
jeunes écrivent les textes et certaines
chansons ce band partout dans le monde
regardez le guitariste par exemple s'il
vend des centaines de milliers d'albums
[Musique]
vous savez chaque génération à sa façon
de parler
alors ce que je fais c'est simplement
moderniser le message la bigne
[Musique]
une modernité qui plaît énormément aux
moins de 25 ans ils représentent plus
d'un tiers des membres de new là des
chiffres qui font pâlir d'envié l'église
catholique qui elle peine à attirer les
jeunes
[Musique]
au sein d'une amie chrétiens les
évangélistes ont le plus fort taux de
croissance il y à une méga église
évangiles qui ouvre ses portes tous les
deux jours aux états unis et quand je
dis méga église est une église de plus
de 2000 fidèles
nous enseignons la bible comme chez les
catholiques à la seule différence que
nous en tirons un enseignement en
pratique est ce pour la vie de tous les
jours et nous le faisons sans utiliser
des mots que les gens ne comprennent pas
mais c'est plus du marketing religieux
que de la religion non non c'est de la
communication religieuse
une communication religieuse qui a
permis aux évangélistes de convertir des
millions d'américains même parmi les
plus récalcitrants comme marc patrie
si on vous avait dit que vous seriez à
l'église tous les dimanches vous
l'auriez cru
alors bien sûr que non
[Musique]
mais cette église est vraiment
différente elle est tellement de monde
et puis pour les enfants c'est vraiment
génial
[Musique]
la messe est dite et une centaine de
nouveaux membres vont enfin pouvoir se
faire baptiser dans une eau chauffée
hammam et de nous
[Musique]
à
au nom du père du fils et du
saint-esprit je te baptise
vous étiez catholique oui je n'étais
alors pourquoi vous convertir
aujourd'hui pourquoi eh bien mon fils
m'a dit qu'il voulait être baptisé enfin
immergé et ma fille aussi c'est notre
première fois une oeuvre a peur non
pourquoi parce que je suis assez
courageuse pour recevoir le christ dans
mon coeur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et ans
[Musique]
ils sont baptisés dans un bassin en
forme de croix car c'est le symbole du
christ mort pour nos péchés et donc moi
j'accepte de mourir pour les autres
[Musique]
après la messe dans la salle des fêtes
de l'église un millier d'adolescents se
retrouvent pour la grande danse des
cowboys encadré bien sûr par des
pasteurs évangélistes
sacha la fille de mark patrick est fan
de danse mais elle est un peu choqués
par certaines tenues de ses camarades
[Musique]
ça me dérange quand je vois des filles
ou des garçons qui s'habille sexy
ou qui ne se comporte pas de façon
chasse on dirait un concours de britney
spears oui je sais ça me choque vraiment
on est dans une église c'est un truc
chrétiens ont fait pas des trucs comme
ça dans une église à moi
[Musique]
à l'étagé les tout petits ont le droit à
un groupe est chaud chrétien a new life
quel que soit l'âge il existe une
activité correspondante réalité mon père
me dit qu'il ya eu un big bang et que la
vie est apparue comme ça ah bon et toi
tu crois pas que c'est dieu qui a tout
créé et vous les enfants vous en pensez
quoi est-ce que c'est dieu qui est créé
[Musique]
vous êtes sûr
comme chaque dimanche après midi le
pasteur ted retrouve le calme de son
bureau pour préparer sa réunion
téléphonique avec la maison blanche une
réunion hebdomadaire qui a lieu tous les
lundi matins car en tant que présidente
des évangélistes américains sa voix pèse
lourd dans les décisions politiques du
pays
histoire et vous direct avec la maison
blanche c'est important de rester en
contact vous savez je représente plus de
30 millions d'américains
aux usa il y a le parti démocrate les
républicains et nous les évangélistes
alors la maison blanche peut entendre ce
que nous avons à dire et c'est comme ça
qu'il y ait un président de droite ou de
gauche laisse penser que vous
représentez une solution aux problèmes
du monde absolument notre religion est
la seule solution
car nous respectons les autres nous
sommes la seule religion qui non
seulement veut se faire entendre bien
sûr mais nous sommes aussi prêts à
défendre les libertés religieuses des
eaux
et donc notre religion est à la base de
toutes les libertés
[Musique]
direction washington justement le siège
du pouvoir aux états unis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est ici que les évangélistes
concentrent leurs efforts pour faire de
l'amérique une nation chrétienne cette
bataille se joue ici dans les couloirs
du congrès et du sénat américain
le capitol hill club est l'un des clubs
les plus fermés de la ville réservé
exclusivement aux membres républicains
du congrès et du sénat américain
depuis des semaines maintenant les skis
prépare cette journée
aujourd'hui elle a invité tout le gotha
de la droite américaine pour leur part
les d'abstinence
dans cette salle les conseillers des
hommes politiques les plus puissants des
états unis
ils sont venus se faire une opinion sur
les mérites du programme de leslie
car si elle ne veut pas perdre les 180
millions de dollars de subventions
publiques que l'état lui accorde chaque
année ce sont ces hommes justement
qu'elle doit convainc
l'un d'entre eux est déjà acquis à sa
cause c'est le sénateur sam brownback
l'un des hommes politiques les plus
puissants de washington est l'un des
plus conservateurs aussi
leslie on va bientôt commencer une
prière avant de manger non surtout pas
c'est un lieu public et c'est le
contribuable qui paye le déjeuner
mais le sénateur brunch bac lui ne
s'encombre pas de ses préoccupations
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs je voudrais tout
de même commencer ce repas par une
prière
alors christie si vous pouviez venir et
bénir ce déjeuner
fonds publics ou pas pour le sénateur la
prière est sacré
dans quelques instants je vais vous
présenter une femme qui restera dans
l'histoire de ce pays
sa vision et son courage lui permettront
je l'espère de transformer les états
unis alors c'est avec un grand plaisir
que je vous présente la présidente des
centres pour l'abstinence la plus
importante organisation mondiale pour la
promotion de l'abstinence jusqu'au
mariage
alors sans plus attendre
[Applaudissements]
même si merci à vous tous d'être venus
aujourd'hui pour protéger nos enfants
notre plus précieuses ressources
naturelles
l'abstinence est un programme vital
quand j'ai rencontré le président bush
m'a dit lesley je ne comprends pas qu'il
puisse y avoir des gens qui s'opposent
encore à l'abstinence
c'est la seule façon de protéger notre
jeu
mais ennemis disent que mon programme
est trop radical waes
vous préserver la pureté de nos enfants
si vous leur parlez de préservatifs
l'abstinence est la seule solution pour
notre peau
à la table de leslie le docteur oued
horn sous secrétaire d'état à la santé
c'est lui qui conseille le congrès en
matière d'éducation sexuelle
[Applaudissements]
docteur ce n'est pas un peu dangereux de
mélanger religion et santé je ne mélange
pas religion et santé c'est
biologiquement prouver que l'abstinence
est la seule garantie contre les
maladies sexuellement transmissibles de
l'afe je suis croyant bien sûr mais je
suis aussi un fidèle serviteur de l'état
mon président et mon congrès attendent
de moi des solutions pour protéger les
enfants de ce pays
je le répète ce n'est pas ma foi en dieu
qui lui fait dire que l'abstinence est
ce qu'il y aille mieux et bien mes
connaissances en biologie
le déjeuner a été un succès les
conseillers politiques repartent avec un
dossier sur l'abstinence les skis est
rassurée cette année encore le trésor
américain financera son programme à
hauteur de 200 millions de dollars
j'ai rencontré toutes les personnes que
je voulais voir j'ai réussi à expliquer
qu'il ne fallait pas négocier avec les
partisans de la contraception
les choses vont changer à washington
c'est un combat de longue haleine mais
je suis prête à me battre jusqu'au bout
et toujours sans faire aucune concession
non mais c'est ça
disons juste que si on me cherche on
trouve
mais je vous présente une jeune fille
géniale taylor taylor va nous chanter
une chanson on y va
c'est leur moore à 15 ans elle est venue
spécialement de chicago pour rencontrer
les slips
[Musique]
m
oui et non adieu
alors ouais tu sais
[Musique]
ouais
il ya deux ans
[Musique]
et
le soir même leslie rentrer dans le
dakota du sud à sioux falls
c'est chez elle et en famille qu'elle
veut célébrer sa victoire
leslie est marié à cash depuis 25 ans
leurs cinq enfants se sont tous mariés
vierge et ont tous voté de george bush
lors des dernières élections
brad pitt alors ici on fait tout dans la
tradition américaine
c'est un repas typique du dakota
oui il y à de la pure et du poulet du
stewi
ensuite on va rajouter de la glace ça
aussi c'est assez typique
cette dernière élection reflète le désir
grandissant des américains de retrouver
des valeurs morales des valeurs qui se
sont perdues dernièrement et qui était
pourtant à la base de notre culture
c'est grâce à ces valeurs que notre
famille et si soudée dieu nous a
vraiment bénie
cache le mari de leslie dirige l'un des
plus grands cabinets d'ostéopathie de la
région
nous avons des télécommandes pour tous
et pas que pour l'acheminer si je veux
un sandwich appuie sur un bouton et
peuvent journée 1
c'est super
et cache bien sûr état des premiers fans
de leslie
l'esprit m'a toujours dit qu'il fallait
se réveiller chaque jour et demander à
dieu comment on pouvait lui être utile
et si on fait ça tous les matins alors
tout est possible voudrait on peut même
se donner un nouveau départ en avance de
dieu leslie ça vous est déjà arrivé de
prendre un nouveau départ
oui ça m'est arrivé et plus d'une fois
d'ailleurs
vous savez un moment dans ma vie
j'aurais pu basculer du mauvais côté
indien que j'étais plus jeune et j'étais
un peu perdu comme beaucoup de gens
peuvent l'être dans un certain moment de
leur
voiture et
puis un jour j'ai demandé à dieu
si tu existes vraiment montre toi je
veux changer mais que tf1
d'avant sa rencontre avec dieu les lie à
garder peu de souvenirs
à part peut-être cette chanson qu'elle
aime interpréter en duo avec cache
cache vous êtes contents des changements
en amérique aujourd'hui absolument nous
avons une occasion unique de transformer
notre pays et c'est vraiment excitant
est là nous contrôlons le congrès le
sénat et le président bush a compris
qu'il fallait à tout prix préserver le
patrimoine chrétien de notre pays est là
rien ne peut nous arrêter
être chrétien aujourd'hui c'est avant
tout être militant
a fait appel à des gens comme leslie
pour faire bouger les choses mais il y
en a plein d'autres comme le juge moore
par exemple cas
comme
dopés e
commerce awards
à 80 km plus au
sud
[Musique]
kb
le spa
ça
vous n'allez pas le croire mais on s'est
vraiment marier à las vegas
[Musique]
nous quittons le dakota du sud direction
chicago la capitale économique du nord
de l'amérique
[Musique]
les plus grandes entreprises du monde
ont leurs bureaux dans cette ville
derrière l'acier et le verre de ses
tours de plus en plus d'employés
évangélistes travail pour répandre le
message du christ
ce matin chokri cas le banquier
chrétiens du minnesota a rendez vous
dans l'une de ces entreprises
sur les 2000 employés près de 450 sont
évangélistes
quelques-uns se sont regroupés au sein
du conseil des chrétiens
ce sont eux qui ont fait appel à chuck
scène ils veulent qu'il partage avec
nous son expérience de la fois dans le
travail
[Musique]
dites moi juste ce que vous attendez de
moi ça me ferait très plaisir de pouvoir
revenir et parler à tous les chrétiens
de votre entreprise
vous savez dans ma banque en 24 mois
nous avons conversé remet une 83
personnes
je pense que nous voulons tous avoir une
relation plus intime avec jésus dans
notre cadre professionnel
pourquoi vous tournez vous tous vers
dieu vous savez aux états unis ne sonne
pas tous riches mais disons que nous ne
sommes pas à plaindre non plus beaucoup
d'entre nous ont réussi dans leur
travail nous avons un mail voiture une
maison de campagne même parfois un
bateau mais malgré cette réussite et
tout s'est joué que nous accueillons que
nous reste-t-il vraiment je crois que
nous avons faim faim spirituellement car
les choses matérielles ils ne peuvent
pas nous rendre heureux
une transformation profonde est en train
de s'opérer dans le monde du travail car
je commence à punir les entreprises et
les cadres corrompus
regarder les infos chaque semaine des
pdg se font arrêter pour tel ou tel
scandale financier
madoff aujourd'hui beaucoup d'hommes
d'affaires se disent qu'ils ont intérêt
à changer des tic s'ils ne veulent pas
se retrouver en première page des
journaux
dieu ne va plus tolérer ce type de
comportement
wilton college à une demi heure du
centre de chicago
une autre université chrétienne où sont
formés les futurs dirigeants
d'entreprise qui comme chuck rêve d'un
monde plus mort à la devise est clair
travailler pour le christ et son royaume
chuck a été invité par le responsable du
département des études économiques sa
banque est aujourd'hui devenu un modèle
pour tous ces jeunes étudiants chrétiens
la plupart d'entre vous me connaissent
je suis steve bratzel professeur
d'économie à 8 tonnes
et j'ai le plaisir de vous présenter
tchèque rude car l'un des fondateurs de
la river community bank
cette banque a ouvert ses portes en mars
2003 en tant qu institution chrétienne
invite les mêmes enterré dans ses
fondations et devant l'entrée on peut
lire nous avons confiance en dieu
cheikh rude qu'à va nous parler du rôle
d'évangilisation de son entreprise
alors sans plus attendre le voici
[Applaudissements]
merci nous sommes la banque avec le plus
fort taux de croissance dans tout l'état
du minnesota
le jour de notre ouverture dieu m'a dit
l'abe encore un tel succès que même et
non croyants vont s'y intéresser et
lorsqu'il te demanderont comment tu fais
tu leur diras simplement la vérité
car aujourd'hui vous pouvez convertir
plus de gens sur votre lieu de travail
que dans votre église c'est dans les
entreprises que doit se faire le travail
de dieu n'ayez pas honte de votre foi
emportez la partout avec vous que vous
soyez dans votre entreprise ils ont
accouché chez quick ait pour ça pas
besoin de ministres indiens suivez le
chemin que deux jours vous a réservé et
il s'occupera du reste la princesse
caroline et des
questions
est ce que votre foi influence la façon
dont vous faites crédit comme un chemin
nous sommes une banque commerciale comme
une autre et nous nous plions aux lois
du marché
nous ne faisons pas de favoritisme et
que vous soyez chrétien ou pas même si
effectivement beaucoup de nos clients le
sont
en fait notre foi permet d'établir un
rapport de confiance avec les gens
avant d'accorder un prêt je prie avec
mes clients pour demander à dieu s'il
approuve le projet ou pas
et je vais vous dire demandez conseil a
dû avant de prendre après immobilier
c'est toi travail j'espérais qu'on
pourrait le rencontrer
ça vous a plu c'était génial de pouvoir
enfin vous entendre parler de votre
banque vous êtes vraiment un pionnier
mon frère et moi on voudrait faire la
même chose est sûre le campus on a même
créé une association pour promouvoir la
chrétienté dans le monde du travail
menacer dans les entreprises qui
viennent demanda qu'on vient ici c'est
un endroit idéal pour évangéliser et
nous on est super enthousiaste
ça vous fait plaisir qu'il y ait une
relève
bien sûr vous savez j'ai mis vingt ans à
faire ce que je fais aujourd'hui
mais je pense que cette génération fera
la même chose que moi en vingt mois
le choc est un véritable exemple pour
nous should be elle nous a montré que
nous n'avons pas besoin de dissocier
notre foi chrétienne de notre vie
professionnelle
encore merci vous avez une carte de
visite oui bien sûr
merci monsieur salut les gars bonne
chance
[Musique]
le soir même sur le campus ont fait la
fin du semestre
au programme un concert de rock du rock
chrétien bien sur les 2700 places du
grand amphi se sont vendus en quelques
heures george joffe clé le groupe de ce
soir a déjà vendu plus de quatre
millions d'albums aux usa michael et
président de l'association des élèves du
campus il a longtemps prié pour que
giorgio reflet accepte devenu
j'ai donné ma vie à dieu il est ma seule
lumière le jour du jugement dernier je
veux prendre avec moi le plus de monde
possible et leur ouvrir les portes du
paradis c'est ce que nous voulons tous
ici pour moi c'est dieu qui est cool
vous savez dans cette université les
étudiants veulent vraiment avoir un
comportement qui honore dieu
quelle que soit notre profession plus
tard nous allons tous travailler pour la
gloire de dieu et pas uniquement pour
nos propres intérêts
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tiens
ça
c'est
m
ça ça
[Musique]
non
et
[Musique]
en
bas
[Musique]
seniors i apprécié ce bail
[Applaudissements]
retour à washington
[Musique]
ce matin sur les marches de la cour
suprême toute l'amérique chrétienne
s'est donné rendez vous pour défendre
les dix commandements
de dieu tout puissant nous vous
supplions d'intervenir dans cette
journée d'une importance capitale pour
notre nation
c'est aujourd'hui que la cour entend les
arguments des deux camps d'un côté les
laïcs plaide la séparation de l'église
et de l'état de l'autre les évangélistes
défendre les fondements de la morale
chrétienne
perdu parmi les évangélistes venus en
grand nombre un défenseur de la laïcité
tentent de se faire entendre
je ne veux pas que mes impôts servent à
promouvoir leur religion et a menacé ma
liberté d'expression
l'un des fondateurs de ce pays a dit que
l'avenir les états unis reposer sur un
peuple respectueux des dix commandements
vous n'avez pas le droit d'imposer vos
valeurs chrétiennes aux autres j'ai le
droit de ne pas croire en dieu
moi je te le donne ce droit
vous êtes en train de me le retirer
vous ne voulez pas qu'on vous parle de
dieu et bien nous on ne veut pas
entendre dire que dieu n'existe pas
c'est comme à l'époque du maccarthysme
vous êtes en minorité ici
c'est pas quoi vous dire il ya beaucoup
trop de moutons dans ce pays beaucoup
trop de moutons qui ont besoin de faire
en quelque chose
à quelques mètres de là le révérend
mcdougald un ami personnel du jugement
c'est aussi l'un des organisateurs de
cette manifestation
une révolte se prépare en amérique on
veut nous retirer notre héritage
chrétien
notre pays a été fondé sur la base des
10 commandements nos ancêtres sont venus
en tant que missionnaire pour fonder une
nation chrétienne
400 du texte notre constitution est
tirée directement de la bible est bon
pour marquer la journée les esprits le
révérend macdougall a demandé au juge
moore l'autorisation de faire venir les
fameux 10 commandements à washington
le monument de marbre arrive tout juste
de l'alabama mais sans autorisation
walter nous sommes en place à et le
monument est bien arrivé devant la cour
suprême c'est la première fois vous le
voyez oui oui c'est la première fois que
je vais le voir de si près j'en ai
tellement entendu parler et vous n'avez
pas le droit de vous garer ici
nous voulons simplement montrer les dix
commandements
je ne veux pas le savoir il faut partir
vous me présentez votre permis de
conduire vous partez sur le champ c'est
mon permis oui le permis ou déplacer ce
camion donnez moi une seconde je le
cherche
bon allez ça suffit dégagez moi ce
véhicule tout de suite
les dix commandements repartent pour
l'alabama
finalement les juges de la cour suprême
ne statue rompt pas
[Musique]
nous partons à 2000 kilomètres de là à
dallas au texas
c'est le fief du président de george
bush un état grand comme la france
sur le parking de ce centre commercial
une réplique en carton des dix
commandements signal aux clients la
présence exceptionnelle du juge moore
le juge est venu promouvoir le livre qui
raconte le récit de son combat
déjà vendu à plus de cent mille
exemplaires les fans du juge se pressent
pour un autographe
comme chaque fois qu'il fait des
signatures des américains de tout âge et
de tout milieu vienne le soutenir dans
sa volonté d'imposer les dix
commandements comme pilier de la justice
américaine
je m'appelle sony dédicace pour moi et
une autre pour ma soeur qui habite en
alabama
soutenons parce que le juge nous avons
même fait une donation à votre formation
on vous aime on vous soutient
vous venez d'où darlington
je vous le dis la fin des temps arrive
et c'est maintenant que nous avons
besoin d'hommes comme le juge moore pour
combattre tout cela tous les gauchistes
c'est bien clair
que dieu vous bénisse
regarde ce que j'ai acheté
cheveux qu'il me le signe
ici en bas
c'est beau hein
et la séparation entre l'église et
l'état vous en faites quoi
la question ce n'est pas ça ça n'a rien
à voir
c'est dieu qui permet au gouvernement
existe vous comprenez
nous ne voulons pas vivre ce que vous
avez vécu en france nous ne voulons pas
de révolution française
mais il risque d'y avoir une révolution
chrétienne on continue à vouloir ignorer
la parole de dieu dans notre pays
vous pouvez m'écrire votre passage
préféré la bible
je faisais partie du côté obscur avant
mais aujourd'hui j'ai changé ma vie
c'est la différence entre nous et les
autres une fois qu'on a vu la lumière
le côté obscur le côté obscur c'est
celui qui n'obéit pas à ceux qui ne suit
pas ses commandements
et pourquoi vous porter des bracelets de
couleur
celui ci c'est pour me rappeler qu'il
faut prier pour la paix en israël vous
les français vous a manqué un peu non
celui là c'est pour nos soldats
et enfin le dernier c'est pour abolir
l'abornement dans notre pays
à chaque fois que je prie je suis aussi
pour s'être chose
monsieur le juge certains détracteurs
disent que votre mouvement est en train
de s'essouffler vous en dit quoi
vous voulez dire que c'est un peu mon
dernier tour de piste
non je ne crois pas car sans dieu il
n'ya pas d'amérique non je vais vous
dire ce que les gens veulent en amérique
aujourd'hui c'est un retour à de vraies
valeurs morales
ce renouveau de la foi chrétienne n'est
pas un événement unique dans notre
histoire
mais l'envergure de ce réveil est sans
précédent
rob moore a décidé de quitter la
magistrature pour la politique
est ce qu'il va falloir vous appelez
gouverneur à jour
seulement si je suis élu
un gouverneur évangélistes c'est
peut-être pour demain pas au texas mais
en plein milieu de l'océan pacifique
ah ah ouais
[Musique]
motards grosse bague surf et bikini
c'est derrière ces images de carte
postale que s'est implanté le mouvements
évangélistes le plus radical du pays
je crains qu'un et sa femme viennent sur
l'île régulièrement
aujourd'hui le banquier chrétien a
rendez vous avec le vice gouverneur de
l'état
depuis son élection il ya deux ans james
doukha yona veut faire d'hawaï un modèle
de coopération entre l'église et l'état
c'était sérieux ça fait plaisir de vous
revoir je vous présente la femme
lors de mon dernier voyage ne
m'accompagne est pas en tout cas ça me
fait plaisir de vous rencontrer
choc profite de son rendez vous pour
faire un peu de lobbying auprès du tout
nouveau vice-gouverneur
lorsque vous verrez la vice gouverneur
du minnesota
j'aimerais que vous me parliez de ce que
dieu est en train de faire ici un game
shima paix et au calme
elle est chrétienne
mais je sais qu'elle n'ose pas trop
parler de sa foi
alors dis tu de m'appeler je veux pris
avec elle pour une autre étape le
minnesota
d'ailleurs ça ne vous gêne pas si
longtemps son
seigneur bénissez hawaï et merci d'avoir
fait élire un homme comme le
vice-gouverneur un homme beau au coeur
pur
seigneur que cette île soit bénigne pour
toujours
aimé
ce n'est pas très bien vu de mélanger
ouvertement politique et religion
mon but n'est pas d'entrer dans le débat
stérile sur la séparation entre l'église
et l'état juste mon but c'est d'être au
service de dieu
d'être son représentant est de montrer
la voie à suivre à tous mes concitoyens
à marcq pourquoi est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
tout à coup je cacherai le fait que je
vais à l'église tous les dimanches
pourquoi cacher que je crois en dieu que
je prie je n'ai rien à cacher
prenez l'exemple du président
aller à la source de son pouvoir de sa
force et de sa vision
et bien il ne fait aucun doute pour moi
que c'est grâce à sa foi qu'il est un
grand
le message est passé et passera sans
doute auprès de la vice gouverneur du
minnesota
[Musique]
l'après midi chaque bien sûr est invité
à parler de sa banque par des employés
qui désirent monter une cellule
chrétienne dans leur entreprise
je vous ai apporté certains livres qui
peuvent vous aider
en excellente homme d'affaires tchèque a
tout prévu il emmenait avec lui un
carton du livre qu'il vient tout juste
d'écrire
est ce que vous sentez le saint-esprit
parcourir cette pièce regardez j'ai la
chair de poule c'est pas à cause de la
conditionner des mauves indien et dans
nos coeurs comme il est aussi dans mon
bureau et dans tout notre état c'est
incroyable chaque
merci elle est vide
tout d'abord bonjour à tous et merci
encore de m'avoir reçu par mail
avant de commencer je voudrais vous
montrer mon livre c'est l'histoire d'un
écrivain et facile à lire et vous verrez
ce que tu est en train de faire non
seulement dans le monde du travail mais
aussi dans notre ville
en tant que chrétiens nous sommes des
serviteurs de dieu notre mission est
d'évangéliser à de faire entrer dieu
dans le monde du travail à partir de là
dieu prendra la suite des choses
est-ce que ça tu en as déjà essayé
d'attaquer votre banc
fin de l'attaqué spirituellement
le succès de notre banque est à double
tranchant en devenant un exemple pour le
monde entier nous sommes aussi devenus
une cible pour ça que c'est pour ça que
nous devons être irréprochables dans
notre travail c'est le seul moyen de
lutter contre
les séminaires de chuck n'attire pas
encore les pdg
dans cette salle ce sont essentiellement
des employés des ghettos leurs rêves
fédérer un jour à ses deux collègues
chrétiens et en convertir d'autres pour
influencer un jour la direction de
l'entreprise à prendre en compte leur
philosophie de vie
[Applaudissements]
danse
en europe vous devez vous dire les
américains sont complètement fous primo
il réalise george bush et secundo ils
sont obsédés par le christ
mais dieu est en train de transformer
l'amérique
l'europe ne croient plus en dieu depuis
longtemps
mais nous les américains nous n'avons
pas honte de nos croyances
ma mission en tant qu évangéliste c'est
de partager mon amour du christ avec
tout ce qui m'entoure et si possible les
convertir
le soir tchèque est invité dans l'une
des nombreuses communautés qui
fleurissent à hawaï
ici comme à l'époque de la conquête de
l'ouest et des pionniers on préfère
prier à la maison et entre voisins ce
soir c'est à l'occasion d'un
anniversaire
[Musique]
moi seigneur que votre nom soit
sanctifié
nous dédions cette soirée fait que nos
vies ne servent qu'à votre gloire
nous vous demandons au seigneur de nous
donner force et sagesse sont que nos
enfants grandissent avec la même passion
siramy salle
qu'ils vous aiment de toute leur âme
de tout leur coeur et de toute leur
force au nom du christ
ce soir dans cette petite maison de
banlieue ils sont une dizaine de couples
à se retrouver dans la prière
ils sont tous évangélistes et ils ont
tous choisi de vivre leur foi comme les
premiers chrétiens là vivait sans doute
c'est à dire sans règles sans dogmes
imposés ni par un pasteur ni par une
écluse
regardez autour de vous nous sommes une
véritable communauté
je préfère louer le seigneur en
compagnie de mes amis que d'être obligé
chaque dimanche de me rendre dans une
église pour prier pendant une petite
heure
quand je vous dis que je suis chrétien
ça ne fait pas de moi une bête de foire
j'ai le câble sur ma télé je joue aux
jeux vidéo je surf sur internet
je suis quelqu'un de normal sauf que mes
valeurs sont celles des valeurs qui
viennent d'un très long livre la bible
regardez autour de vous regardez le
résultat d'une société qui ne respecte
pas la bible ça ne marche pas
c'est toute une accumulation de choses
c'est ce que l'on voit à la télé les
exemples donnés aux jeunes par les
médias ou par hollywood enfin ce sont de
mauvais exemple
chuck est conquis de retour à el khroub
heures il organisera chez lui sa
première réunion de prière
avec river les églises traditionnelles
sont complètement saturé j'en parlais
l'autre jour avec l'un des pasteurs
nous n'avons plus assez de place dans
les églises pour accueillir tous les
fidèles de la ville alors je pense que
ce qu'ils font ici est une solution
idéale pour résoudre le problème je
trouve ça vraiment génial si le gameplay
se gâter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui mais
[Musique]
retour dans le dakota du sud à sioux
falls
[Musique]
ce soir leslie et son association pour
l'abstinence ont organisé un bal de la
pureté
sa malice
toutes les jeunes filles de la ville
sont invités
à quelques centaines de mètres des
locaux de l'association dans la famille
kirby ok on termine de se préparer bon
qu'est ce que tu vas mettre ce soir
mon ensemble bleu je crois
catherine à 15 ans c'est la cadette de
la famille sa mère caroline est resté
vierge jusqu'à son mariage elle veut
faire en sorte que ces filles suivent
son exemple
kelly tu en penses quoi toi
kelly la fille aînée revient d'un séjour
universitaire d'un an à la sorbonne
tu vas qu'à mettre ce châle bleus
comment ça va pas ensemble
mais s'ils vont très bien ensemble
madonna elle dit toujours qu'il ne faut
pas avoir peur de choquer
ne vous inquiétez pas je n'écoute pas
tous les conseils de madonna j'espère
bien parce qu'avant d'aller un bal de la
pureté ça fait désordre je ne pense pas
que madonna viendrait pourquoi pas elle
ne serait pas invité
ce soir nous allons confirmer la
promesse que nous avons faite rester
vierge jusqu'au mariage
mais pourquoi c'est si important
j'ai grandi avec ses valeurs
on en parle souvent en famille en fait
c'est une promesse que j'ai faite à dieu
je pense que rester pur c'est important
pour lui
depuis que j'ai 10 ans mes parents me
parle de
détails bien sûr mais il me dis
simplement qu'il faut que je rester
vierge jusqu'au mariage
c'est vraiment important
elles ont aussi des bacs de pureté vous
savez quel es tu à la tienne
regardez c'est ça une bague de pureté
vous savez pour mon quinzième
anniversaire
mon père m'a invité au rectorat et m'a
donné cette base c'est le symbole de ma
promesse
catherine du diamant recevoir une
c'est étrange parce qu'en fait on dirait
que vous êtes mariés
c'est vrai on me le demande souvent
est alors vous dites quoi je réponds
simplement que non
et en france de marquer cette bague et
on vous disait quoi
bichat il était choqué c'est une quoi tu
n'as pas couché avec un homme mais il
faut que tu goûtes à saraya alors je
répondais ça va aller je vais sur tv pc
sûr que pour les français c'était
vraiment choquant
le père de kelly steve est un homme
d'affaires important du dakota il est à
la tête d'un gros groupe financier et a
largement contribué à la campagne de
réélection de george bush lui aussi
s'est marié vierge dans les années 70
vous savez l'histoire nous montre que
les civilisations les plus puissantes
ont toutes été fondés sur des familles
moralement ce n est pour obtenir de tels
famille elles doivent tout d'abord être
normalement constitué
c'est à dire avec un homme et une femme
ensuite leurs enfants doivent rester
vierge jusqu'au mariage et les sens que
c'est comme ça que l'amérique restera
une puissance mondiale donc rester
vierge jusqu'au mariage est un acte
patriotique
oui c'est patriotique et c'est un bon
moyen d'aider son pays sa ville son
église une famille scène est à la base
d'un pays sain
dans la salle de bains catherine et
kelly les deux soeurs termine de se
maquiller
mascara bloch rouge à lèvres ce soir
c'est le bal de la pureté mais il n'est
pas interdit de séduire
je vais faire un petit tour d'inspection
et mon dieu pourquoi on fait tout ça
vous passez un tiers de votre vie dans
la salle de bain c'est plus amusant de
se préparer que d'y aller
ça existait les balles de la pureté
quand vous étiez jeune non j'aurais
tellement aimé ça n'existait pas à
l'époque et parisienne je pense que
c'est quelque chose de nouveau
c'est grâce à l'équipe
ouais bon moi je les enfiler mon smoking
c'est étrange de se faire belle pour à
bâle de la pureté non il n'ya rien
d'étrange l'abstinence est super sévère
c'est super mais la majorité des jeunes
trouvent ça en garde du guide the book
vous savez nous on pense qu'en restant
abstinente nous gardons le contrôle de
nos
et cali ça ne t'empêche pas de sortir
avec des garçons
j'aime bien sortir et puis c'est pas
comme si j'allais le strict verges tout
m'est venue j'ai seulement besoin de
tendre et pas de quoi flipper attendre
ton mariage bien sûr est-ce que vous
avez un petit ami non je suis
célibataire et j'adore ça
[Rires]
bon il ne me reste plus qu'à mettre la
touche finale we do savez dans le dakota
du sud nous avons aussi des cowboys
c'est pâques au texas alors je vais
mettre mes bottes des bottes avec le
smoking et oui bien sûr
bottes de cowboy avec un smoking
vous savez le soir après la cérémonie
d'investiture du président bush il ya eu
un gigantesque balle à washington ça
s'appelait le bal des votes texane ou
quelque chose comme ça
douze mille personnes étaient invitées
dans un immeuble de huit étages
alors moi en bon représentant du dakota
j'ai mis ses bottes de cowboy typique de
mon état avec mon smoking
oscar
7h30 la limousine arrive et c'est aussi
le moment de faire une petite prière
seigneur tout puissant bénisse et ce bal
de la pureté ce moment unique réservé
seulement aux pères et à leur fille je
vous remercie aussi que kelly et pu
rentrer de france pour être avec nous ce
soir et nous prions pour une super
soirée
[Musique]
ouarga nourriture comme elle est belle
wahou
à
[Musique]
amusez vous bien mon chéri on
t'appellera
j'ai mis ma chemise
je
suis sûr qu'ils vont passer une très
belle soirée tous ensemble vous n'y
allez pas
je vais rang devant la maison pour moi
tout seul et je vais bien même les
esprits
[Musique]
le bal de l'impureté est réservé
exclusivement aux filles et à leur faire
ce soir kelly et catherine comme une
centaine d'autres qui feront serment
devant leurs pairs de rester vierge
jusqu'au mariage
allez un petit test pour le bal de la
pureté des méfiances et d'un soir
là
ce soir steve s'est engagé à passer
prendre deux autres jeunes filles leur
père est en voyage d'affaires
alors c'est à lui que revient la
responsabilité de les escorter
[Musique]
vous les filles vous avez pas l'âge de
boire de l'alcool alors prenez de l'eau
vous savez souvent aux etats-unis les
grands mouvements nés ce temps de
petites villes comme sioux falls ce ne
sont pas les politiciens de washington
qui nous disent fait ci ou ça
c'est parce qu'il ya des centaines voire
des milliers de gens qui pensent comme
nous et qui sortent âge ces mêmes
valeurs celle d'une amérique
conservatrice que les choses sont en
train de changer sam son chandail
[Musique]
dans la grande salle de bal les premiers
invités profite de la piste de danse
père et fille font leurs premiers pas
ensemble
oh
leslie encore une fois n'a rien laissé
au hasard
orchestre ballons blancs robe de soirée
tout est fait pour donner l'illusion
d'un mariage
je veux faire de ce premier bal de la
pureté un exemple pour tout le pays
je pense que ce type d'événement peut
devenir un succès dans d'autres villes
et puis en tant que présidente du
mouvement pour latine ans si je dis que
ce bal est un super moyen de promouvoir
nos idées on l'écoutera
21h kelly sa soeur et leurs amis
arrivent enfin
comme à chaque jeune fille une rose
blanche leur est offerte à l'entrée le
symbole de leur pureté
regardez comme il est beau votre père
leslie réserve un accueil privilégié à
la famille kirby elle sait que steve le
père a des appuis politiques importants
à washington les 150 invités sont
arrivés la soirée peut commencer
elle débute par une avant première la
projection du dernier spot publicitaire
financé par l'association
dans ce clip un ado se voient proposer
de choisir entre deux bouteilles d'eau
[Musique]
brusquement une dizaine d'autres jeunes
sortent d'une camionnette et boivent au
goulot de sa bouteille
et ils font quoi l'un
quand ils ont fini on lui propose alors
de boire à son tour
bien sûr il refuse même contredit
dollars
il préfère l'autre bouteille celle qui
n'est pas passée de bouche en bouche
celle qui est plus
pur comme une fille vierge avant le
mariage
la preuve est faite
[Rires]
après le clip c'est l'heure du serment
[Applaudissements]
dans la bible les pères sont souvent
représentés comme des guerriers de
grands chasseurs ou encore dr ou moins
vieux a fait de vous des pères guerrier
avec pour seule mission de protéger vos
enfants
mesdemoiselles la promesse que vous
ferez ce soir servira à honorer votre
père votre famille et notre dieu tout
puissant
alors cette phase à votre père et
répétez après moi en puisant dans la
force vitale de mon père
je promets solennellement adieu
à ma famille et à moi même
à mon futur mari et à mes futurs enfants
que je resterai sexuellement pur
jusqu'au jour où je m'offrirai
en cadeau de mariage à mon épouse
mes demoiselles ce soir vous promettez
souvenez-vous de cette promesse tout au
long de votre vie
quant à vous monsieur
protéger vos filles comme des princesses
pas cuit pour qu'elle arrive vierge à
leur fille
et maintenant priant
[Musique]
ce n'est pas un peu gênant d'avoir son
père à côté de soi lorsqu'on parle de sa
virginité
c'est peut-être un peu étrange
mais c'est vraiment une décision très
importante
je pense qu'il faut en parler avec son
père comme on parle de ses études donc
ce n'est pas si étrange que ça
moi ça me gêne un peu
vous savez c'est toujours difficile
d'aborder avec vos enfants les sujets
délicats c'est sûr que pour lui dire de
lire un livre est d'avoir de bonnes
notes à l'école c'est simple
mais lui dire de rester sexuellement pur
c'est vraiment difficile
après le dîner chaque fille escorté de
son père rien déposé une rose blanche
devant cette croix
pour se rappeler que cette promesse elle
l'a aussi fait devant dieu
[Musique]
alors les filles maintenant vous êtes
impatient de trouver un mari
on est trop jeune pour penser à sa faim
moi j'y pense de temps en temps toi
petite soeur tu as le temps inquiète pas
il est comment votre mii des halles
comme tout le monde quoi il faut qu'il
soit charmant
fort aussi oui très musclé
et chrétiens bien sûr non ouais
absolument s'il n'est pas chrétien quand
je le rencontre je le convertirait
son bal et un succès demain l'esl il
exportera dans des centaines de petites
villes américaines
j'espère que l'amérique va changer quand
je vois toutes ces jeunes filles toutes
elles-mêmes viennent déposer ses roses
devant la croix c'est un bon signe pour
l'avenir et de darou personne ne les a
forcés à la famille monnaie
allez en rythme les filles
[Musique]
non
à